[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video I'm going to
talk about some major spoilers that were
dropped at the Comic Con experience in
Brazil the gimmick turn-screw arrived on
a panel to discuss the upcoming season
and some of them accidentally spoiled
the fate of their characters such as
season 8 is over The Game of Thrones
show runners David Benioff and Dan Weiss
took the stage in Brazil a few days ago
for a panel discussion at Comic Con
experienced the cast members Maisie
Williams started stark and John Bradley
similarly joined them for a fun Q&A
session they look back on a decade of
Game neuroscientist season eight however
it's not for some major spoilers for opt
it's Williams and Bradley sat down for a
Facebook live interview with HBO Brazil
which resulted in some great insights
into how they view their characters the
show's evolution and the spoiler we are
going to talk about in spheria the most
interesting was Williams answer when
asked what has been the most exciting
moment for aria in the series so far and
she replied some of the most exciting
are coming in season 8 so I can't talk
much about him later in an interview
when asked if we're going to see more
epic scenes from aria she replied they
really really are however it's not
Maisie Williams who spoiled fate of our
character aria it's John Bradley who
spoiled fate of his character Sam how
did they feel about filming their last
scenes was the question to which Bradley
responding the way --then answered that
seemingly cludes a huge spoiler many
fans circle means that Bradley gave away
a big spoiler and it's about his
character Sam surviving to the end let's
take a look on the clip I feel exactly
the same every year we've gone back and
we put that skin on again and we and
we've become those characters again and
Sam it may be a very painful part to
play with a lot of pain in it and a lot
of heartache in there but it was always
a nice place to go back to to kind of
touch base with him again and just see
how he is and just to think that I'm
never gonna I feel like I'm abandoning
him coming off because I'm never gonna
see how he is again and I just hope that
funny enough they become real people and
you just hope that they're happy but to
know that you're never gonna touch base
with them again and you just kind of
left them to do their own thing it's
kind of hard it's emotionally a real
emotional separation I think Bradley
said it'll be hard not going back to
check on the character Sam he feels like
he's abandoning him what it means is
that his character survives the game of
Thrones and it's hard for him to know
that he's never again going back in game
eternal to check on Sam and his life
that
Nate is over if Sam died it would not be
hard for him to never go back to check
on the character in fact if Sam dies
Bradley could not even check on him and
see how he's doing
also Bradley would not feel like he's
abandoning Sam if Sam was not alive
after season 8 so there's that although
to be honest most of us have expected
him to survive and now it's confirmed
Sam survives the game throws does this
ultimately spoiled at the living valve
in is up to you to decide for yourself
but in my opinion it's definitely not
spoiling the outcome of the Great War
this revelation however besides spoiling
faith of similarly might also stand as a
confirmation of a popular fan theory
michsam is actually the one narrating
the Game of Thrones thus he has to
survive the events of games to be able
to narrate it over a year ago I
introduced with this eerie image the
story of Game of Thrones has already
been written down and is this whole time
being narrated by similarly in the
previous season hinted at big time
before I show you a strong hint from
season 7 episode 2 that is going favor
to this theory let me first briefly
introduce you with the whole thing about
same being the narrator of Game of
Thrones basically I came up to this
theory while reading John Bradley
scenarios an actor that portrays
similarly in series rarely came up with
the theory based on the object in the
game of Thrones opening credits that is
identical to Diaz he said gyroscope this
is hanging inside a citadel John Bradley
theorized and might have even figured
out the game of transcending Bradley
said I think it could mean any number of
things one theory is that what we're
seeing now and have experience in game
materials since I'm telling the story of
Game of Thrones if you take the logic of
the story now the story of Westeros and
the story of the battle for the Iron
Throne it would be a book in that
library the visual motif of that is
you're about to be told the story the
sense of an idea being told a story in
people gaining the knowledge the way Sam
is absorbing knowledge in the library
this is a great theory when you look at
it each and every episode of Game of
Thrones has sorry the same way ever
since the show began with the same
opening credits while we have always
been wondering what one particular
object that looks like mechanical son is
the origin of this and one more object
was finally revealed in season 6 finale
some finally entered the library and
there it is chandelier looking
attraction that looks exactly like the
Esther Leafs an object from the opening
credits that have been watching for
seven years in all 67 episodes
what's the purpose of this chandelier
looking at rap scene in Citadel just as
it looks like at first glance one of its
functions is to reflect sunlight from
the window high above around the room
over mirrors because the Masters who use
then maintain the library would never
ask a man
else anywhere near books however the
most important function of astrolabe or
more accurately armillary sphere is to
locate and predict positions of the
stars and planets in order to provide
local time and more these functions of
the tremendous importance for the
maesters of the citadel as it helps them
to determine when the long season
service rose officially begin an end
about which day then informed castles
and cities of the Seven Kingdoms by
standing out white Raymond's to share
the news in this theory however the s
truly been a changing map of Westeros
that we see before every single episode
represent the unfolding of a story being
told by Sam himself as it can be seen
the creator so the title sequence
decided to place the map on the inner
surface of a sphere a written Esther
Leafs an object at the center the camera
would then visit different parts of the
map while illustrations on yes relate
covered some of the backstory to the
show as we all know the game of Thrones
title sequence introduces every episode
and changes depending on the locations
visited in that particular episode the
opening credits consist of a
three-dimensional map of the world with
the continents of Westeros and Essos
located on the inner surface of a sphere
at the center of the spheres light
source effectively a Sun surrounded by
an s really black arrangement of
rotating rings the sequence opens with a
close-up of the Sun and the s reliefs
surrounding it well the most interesting
parts are to relieve details they're
visible on the astrolabe in both Game of
Thrones opening credits and in world's
greatest library since those two are
actually the same object really details
on the table jacket are showing a
volcano destroying a city while dragon
watch is on and several people escaping
in a boat a reference to the doom of
Valyria and the Targaryen escaped from
it after a few moments there's another
closeup of the detail on yes relate this
time showing the stark direwolf
Lannister lion Baratheon stag engaging
the Targaryen dragon in combat reference
to Robert's rebellion the less close-up
of the relief detail on the astrolabe
which is also the ending of the title
sequence is now showing the animals
representing the various noble houses of
Westeros bowing to the victorious
Baratheon stag the Game of Thrones logo
then appears overlaid with the heads of
a dragon wolf lion and a stag emerging
from the side of the logo season 6
provided us one more proof that is going
favor to this theory when same arrives
at the Citadel he is greeted by maester
who uses a distinctive pair of glasses
to read the text in front of him
those glasses to be exact its lenses
feature most probably seen in each
episode of gaming journals in the
opening credits as you can see in every
title sequence while zooming in on city
of King's Landing and while zooming out
of the wall the map is actually seen
through lenses that appeared to be just
like those
now let's see how this theory might have
been confirmed or least hinted in season
7 well our Schmidt cerebros and Sam were
gathering books instead of a library
archmaester said the line that seems to
be a strong hint for Sam truly being the
narrator of Game of Thrones
have to do the research to read your
histories you need a bit of style I'm
not writing a chronicle of the wars
following the death of King Robert the
first so he can sit on the shelf
I'll read what you don't like the title
what would you call it there possibly
something a bit more poetic we're not
poet Epiphone is now also Song of Ice
and Fire which was later adapted into
the HBO series Game of Thrones most
certainly does sound more poetic this
marks the biggest game that Game of
Thrones series might end we told Sam
looking up from a book as he finally
read the whole story this would mean
that all the events that we've seen and
all the events that we're about to see
had already taken place and are actually
written in Sam's book that he is reading
to someone don't you think George our
modern would fit perfectly as the old
Sam who is looking up from book as he
finally reads the whole story to either
little Sam or John and Danish child or
even to both of them well this would be
Martin's first appearance in game Jones
it most certainly would not be the first
time the showrunner decided to pay the
respect towards George try the show even
though this will be the most important
and the most noticed one in fact the
showrunners already mentioned george RR
martin and his genius mind several times
for the show I'm sure there are a few
mangas the remember Mockingbird the
blue-eyed giant it's according to some
stories investors reason why the sky is
blue is according to legend an entire
known world is a tiny object floating in
the eye of macabre however in A Song of
Ice and Fire novels there's no legend
about the sky being bloom because the
entire world is in the eye of a
blue-eyed giant named Macomber
nor any comparable fable but as being
said it's pretty easy to conclude that
may embrace a meta-narrative reference
to the author george RR martin since the
entire fictional universe originated
inside of his head george RR martin was
already supposed to play a role in Game
of Thrones when he filmed a cameo
appearance in unaired pilot episode of
Game of Thrones as a background pentoshi
merchant him in minded he was already
supposed to appear in the series george
RR martin purring all the same in the
last scene of gammatron series most
early doesn't seem to be out of the
realm of possibilities additionally
during one interview martin said that if
he was in the story he
probably be similarly he's a great
character Martin said Tyrion might be
who I want to be but Sam is probably
closer to who I actually am the fat kid
who likes to read books and doesn't like
to go up a lot of stairs long story
short is B Hinton and for share of that
game appearance would end up with an old
same looking from the book as he
finishes reading or writing old events
the only problem fans have with this
theory of Sam being the narrator of Game
of Thrones would be its credibility if
all of this for events written in Sam's
book can really believe everything
that's been told to us artist arcs
really the good ones and our Delaney's
are surely the valence of the story what
fans are trying to say is that seems
look and events could be biased or the
stars and Jon Snow and therefore defense
might have not happen exactly as we've
been told
however if this theory does in fact come
true if gimmick Ron Julie ends with old
Sam narrating the game turns to someone
with george RR martin when training him
I can tell you for a fact that we can
believe that old events happened just
like it's been told to us without Sam
being biased towards the Starks and Jon
Snow how do we even know that Sam even
knows exactly all the events when he's
not even been in most of them for
example how would seem know the
conversation between some characters
when he's not even being anywhere close
to them well his brain the only person
who could go back in time and see
whatever Sam asked him to see which is
exactly what happened in season seven
months Ms Brown to check if the marriage
between Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
stark actually happened in conclusion
this John Braley's theory that support
with view proves definitely sound
interesting and after all what better
way to end the game internals then with
george RR martin himself the one who
created this world in the first place
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace
[Music]